kristen what is up i need some help
walking through
a little issue i'm having i am getting
married april 11th
next year um and my mom is in prison
she's been in prison
for a little over a year now
um she's been in and out of prison my
entire not really prison this is her
second time being in prison but she's
been in and out of jail my entire life
um we were super lucky my grandma took
my sister and i in and raised us from
when we were like
three um mom's not really been a great
mom but she
uh i mean she's my mom i love her i want
her to be at my wedding
um she has been doing really great
this time around i think she's finally
kind of figuring out that this is either
gonna kill her or
she will you know kind of grow up
um but i see i'm getting
married on the 11th and if she when she
finishes this program
she will maybe be released
um on the 5th of april so
we're not sure if i should push back the
wedding
so i know that she will be out it kind
of just depends on who's in a good mood
and who's not
or if we should leave the wedding as it
is and if she's there
she's there and if she's not she's not
um so kristen
how many times have you planned things
in your life
and mom didn't show up everything
everything yeah how many times
have you opened your heart yet again to
have your heart broken
forever forever all right so nobody
i i don't know anybody in my circle that
believes in redemption more than i do
i don't know anybody in my circle of
friends in community
that goes on the regular basis says
let's give that person one more shot one
more chance i'm that guy
okay yeah
but you've got to let the fantasy go
yeah
and you are still hoping and dreaming
and putting your heart
back out there again that this is going
to be the time this is going to be the
time
i think you should go ahead and have
your wedding you should plan your
wedding if your mom is out that will be
great and a bonus
and if she is reformed and healthy and
lovely and wonderful that is so good
so good but she's probably not going to
be
yeah i thought you'd say that
and i don't want you to set yourself up
this really important benchmark moment
this moment when you are joining futures
with somebody else i don't want you to
hinge that
on a myth on a fantasy right okay
this relationship with your mom can heal
and it can take
years and years and years and years to
heal
and it's going to start with little
breakfasts and it's going to start with
getting together once a month it's going
to start rebuilding trust
that trust is hers to build not yours it
doesn't mean you don't love her it
doesn't mean you're not connected with
her
but it does mean that this time your
grandparents are there
this time your awesome fiance your
husband's going to be there
move forward with the date if she makes
it great if she doesn't
great and
i hate saying that out loud now because
i'm just sitting here saying it i hate
it
because i i believe so strongly in
honoring our father and mother i believe
so strongly in
honoring wisdom of people who are older
than us and have more experience than us
but i also know that parents just they
cash in their parent card
they're abusive they are addicts they've
got their own demons that they wrestle
with
and they push their kids aside as they
deal with those things
they break the law they end up in jail
over and over and over and over again
and at the end of the day we can love
them we can honor them we can be
respectful for them
and we can also go and continue to live
our lives
and there's a tension there and it's not
one and it's not the other
but there's a tension there
so you got to hold them both and right
now kristen i want you to plan your
wedding
once you've got a date everyone's going
to be there if your mom's there it'll be
one of those fairy tale things that'll
make for a good video
and if she's not you're not going to get
your heart broken again you're not going
to move everything around just for her
so thank you so much for that call go
get them and hey when your mom gets out
call me
when your mom gets out call me both of
you all call me kristen i want to hear i
want to celebrate her
and hopefully she gets done and makes
that wedding that'll be awesome